So far, we focused on helping users
fill out forms faster by, well,
not filling out anything.
But now, I want you to think
about your users confidence,
with good validation features.
With validation,
you can ensure that users know
that they are filling forms
with the right information.
More importantly,
validation can ensure that the users
fill out form correctly the first time.
They won't waste time leaving an input
and submitting a form only to find
out a few seconds later that they
forgot a digit in their zip code.
With validation, you are giving
your users a real time feedback and
minimizing errors.
I want to choose a new password,
and like in any good website,
I have a few rules
that I need to enforce.
Here, while i'm typing, you could
see that I'm using lowercase, and
now I understand that I need an
uppercase, as well, I need few numbers,
and I just passed the minimum
length of eight characters.
I'm adding some punctuation, and
only then, I'm enabling the next button.
It's worth adding that HTML file
validation or any front end validation,
for that matter, is not a replacement
for a service side validation.
Your websites are obviously not safe,
unless you validate
on your back end too.
The approach Cam and
I are discussing is just
a way to improve the user experience,
and to put a big smile on the faces.
In the next video, I'll show you how
to use HTML5 attributes for validation.